(intro music)
(audience applauds)
- Have y'all ever met before?
- We met very briefly at a movie
that she was in that was so
good earlier this summer.
- Yeah.
- So your new song is called Bad Idea.
So what it's what It's
obviously about a bad idea.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, whoa.
- Well I was gonna ask you,
but I think it's probably
about a bad idea.
- Yeah.
- This is so cool.
- Thank you!
- All the artistic stuff that you do.
- Thanks, yeah.
- Yes!
- No, I know, we were,
we were in Paris and we were
feeling the fashion week energy.
And so we had these bleached
brows, which people are very
very mixed reviews on these bleach brows.
Yeah. But
- Like, I hate it.
You look like that.
You can do anything you want.
Oh, so your single boyfriend came.
It became an anthem for
LGBTQ+ community, all of us.
I love the song, thought was so clever.
Did you write that for you, really?
Or did you write that
just because of a situ?
Like why did, what, why
was that in your head?
- Yeah, honestly, it's
funny, it's, I wrote it based
on a really, kind of like,
rough experience that I had
that I would never,
like if you told me then
that I was gonna write
that song about that night
it's like so incongruous
and, kind of like, very
different energies.
And I ended up with a sort
of a, like a perspective
that I could sit with, right?
Yeah. Which is that, like, instead of,
instead of facing the fact
of, like, someone being a very
harmful person in my life, it was,
I could be a better boyfriend
than this situation that was
going on that I was, you know,
a part of or witnessing.
And I really never
I never thought I was
gonna play it for anybody.
I never thought anybody was gonna hear it.
I was just like, I think
this kind of smacks.
So I was like, I play this.
- Oh my God, I love it.
I literally the first time I heard it.
I listened, like, 20 times in a row.
I was like, "This is a jam!"
- Thank you.
- I love it.
It's so good.
- Oh, thank you.
- How do you feel like
it may have changed you?
Do you feel like, 'cause
sometimes I feel like,
one, it's important to
write and that's my vessel
of like therapy almost.
But then, you get to perform
it all the time and then
it like carries that place with you.
That can be hard.
Does it, do you keep that
or does it, or do you change
and you grow after that?
Sometimes it's hard to re-sing something.
You're like, ugh.
- No, I would imagine
as well, you know, a lot
of your music is so, you're
so, you're very emotive,
you know.
It's very story based, right?
Narrative.
I definitely find,
specifically with boyfriend,
because it was such a
huge part of me finding my
own identity and embracing my queerness.
And it, like, makes me emotional
every time I talk about it.
But it was such a, like,
a key to a gate for me,
into stepping into myself wholly
in a way that I never knew
if I was gonna be privileged enough
to find those pieces of
myself and, and exist
as that person, right?
'Cause that's like the fear.
The fear is that you
exist as yourself wholly,
and the world cracks
open, and everything ends,
and all the lights go out.
And when the song came out,
and when I saw the people
were emotionally connecting to it,
I think I was really
panicked for some reason,
just cause I wasn't expecting it.
- Yeah.
- And then over time,
it was like, it melded
into this gorgeous, like
something meaningful
for me being something
meaningful for others.
I'm sure you've had that before.
- Yeah.
- It's, it becomes this
like, especially when
it's something about, you know, identity,
and queerness, and how
people view themselves being.
- Something so personal and intimate.
- And finding empowerment in
it when it's something that,
you know, can sometimes feel very heavy
to carry alone, identity.
- Yeah.
- And I've found it incredibly
special, and meaningful,
and such a surprise.
Such a beautiful surprise.
- Yeah. I like taking any kind of negative
and making a positive out of it.
- Yeah.
- And possibly making
some money off that too.
So, I mean, you're a writer as well.
You get that too, like in a sense
of like relating to them and
connecting to them in that way.
- I think with writing, for
like, particularly the cast
of College Girls, they're so
funny, and they're so great,
and you get rewrite the narrative.
Like I get to write these
four girls and show how
they relate, and how they
get over their issues,
but can come together even
though they're so different.
They're like socioeconomically different,
like, racially different.
And that you can make it so
that it's like harmonious,
and they're friends.
And, like, I think sometimes
when you create those things
then you allow other people
to see them, and be like,
oh it, that is possible, right?
- Totally.
- And they're so talented,
these four actresses.
And like, I just, I
learned so much from them.
And sometimes, we're
conditioned as writers to think
about people who are older
than us who came before us
and say like, "Hey, they inspire me,"
but I really am inspired
by the young women
that I work with, you know, every day.
And it makes me a better writer.
- I know.
I feel like a lot of
people will, and I'm 40,
I don't know how old you are.
I'm not gonna ask you,
but I just mean like,
I feel like in my generation,
I feel like a lot of people are like,
"Oh, the young generation
is so apathetic," or
"I'm worried about it," or whatever.
And I'm like, I actually,
having this show specifically,
like, I've seen so many
young people, like,
they're more, I mean, I don't know.
I feel like they're advocates,
like, far more than I was
at their age.
- Passion, on 100.
- And more empathy.
It's a different kind of generation,
and it's actually, I think hopeful.
Like, for the people that I encounter
that are a different generation than me,
that are younger.
- I feel like I always
went into it being like,
"I don't wanna be one of those
older people that's always
complaining about the younger people."
And I find myself doing
that a lot, you know?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause, it's just nature.
Like, you just get annoyed at people.
You think it was easier
for them or whatever,
but one thing that is undeniable about,
at least the young women
I work with and see,
is how they're unafraid to be activists.
When I was coming up, I was
like, I don't want anyone to
think I'm like so political,
or self confident,
or think I demand rights and
all this privilege, you know?
- Oh my God, girl, I'm
from the south, yeah.
- Yeah, and so now to see
young women who are, like,
unafraid to do that,
especially in Hollywood,
it's like very, it's very refreshing.
But then also, you know,
makes you think like, "Oh,
I could have done a better
job when I was younger.
- I know.
But you know what it is
though, like what you said,
that's what's so cool, is
that you're setting this up
for even this generation
to, 'cause these are
applicable things to their, to
these people in their lives.
Like you just said, you're
bringing people together
that maybe wouldn't normally
be brought together, especially
on TV, but maybe even in life still.
And then, maybe there's
people in college going,
"That's kinda like my group."
Or like, "This could be my group."
"I wanna find that group."
I love how writing and
creativity and art can do that.
- I mean, there's nothing I
feel like more influential
than storytelling in
like, any form, right?
It's like, you know,
songwriting, TV, film,
like there was nothing
that I learned more from
than those mediums.
Which is why I think we're all here.
So, you know.
- Yeah. They're powerful.
Well, we have a surprise for you.
- You have a surprise for me?
- Yes, we do that.
- What does that mean?
- In honor of over 1 million records sold,
man, we're excited to present you with
the R-I-double-A platinum edition
for your new single "Boyfriend."
(audience applauds)
- Thank you so much.
- I was so excited when
we out you getting it,
I was like, "I wanna give it to her."
Dove's latest single is called Bad Idea,
and it's available wherever
you get your music.
Check it out, y'all.